could you both right now
could you do Will and Grace could you do
wings with the workload and and all that
could you do it right now oh yeah
because I mean I think this the dirty
secret of sitcom is that it's not that
many hours a week right it's the writers
that work harder it's the people
building the sets
um but for me I I found that because the
reboot just ended a couple of years ago
I mean that is a kind of
um Sprint for me that's a fabulous
Sprint whereas I think doing an
hour-long show out of town away from
your family hours a day oh so this seems
at night I mean yeah I mean small people
and you're in my favorite town of
Vancouver is my favorite town I love it
it was a great time it is and uh but
it's that that takes it out of you that
is a different commitment than the sort
of quick party that sitcom but it's
sitcoms to me kind of make me a little
nervous because I did them I did a
couple of short-lived ones for two years
and two years and that you know changing
lines on you last minute and throwing
stuff at you it was just like like I it
was always so nerve-wracking that night
or that week that I was just like oh I
just collapsed on a Saturday for me it
was just like oh my I remember they
threw like this little monologue at me
and they go hey and right before we went
on you're gonna do this like yeah I go
what the f I I can't and I remember I
said my dad was in the audience and I'm
and I I struggle I need to like have let
it sink in and take my time and yeah and
it it was really nerve-wracking but you
didn't feel that way I think that that
you know For Better or Worse that's a
facility that I have that or at least
had that that I I loved that challenge
to me it was like you know when you see
DJs making up on the spot it's a
gift and I loved I loved when they would
throw that at us and as time would buy
particularly when with the reboot of
willing Grace it was less and less of
that it was more like oh God what are
you changing what really
um particularly for the girls they were
like don't give me what are you doing I
just memorized this today I love I love
the chat challenge of hitting the
audience with something that they can
see the writers just wrote that's a
that's a cool did anybody struggle on
either of the shows that you guys have
worked on with like clients have you
dealt with actors that are just like
they yeah like they just can't do it
like you guys yeah well well like you
guys I mean it's it's just it becomes a
practiced thing and when you're a guest
actor as you know you walk on to uh you
know a train that's already in motion it
can be daunting unless you're up for the
challenge and most people are but there
I there was some wonderful actors on
wings that had the worst time now PS
even on the show Chicago Med where
you're doing all this kind of uh medical
records crap that should only be read
off a label on Pharmaceuticals not meant
to be spoken loud that is murder you
know and I've adopted all sorts of
Tricks as a result but yeah that happens
people but also like uh you know uh Pat
Hingle remember the actor Pat Hingle he
passed away he played Commissioner
Gordon in uh Tim Burton's Batman oh wow
among other things an award-winning
actor great actor he did
an episode of wings this guy that
started in you know in live TV in the
50s and won obese and and Tony's and all
that stuff and he was absolutely I
almost say thrown but he was so turned
off by
this loud kind of Pumped up genre you
know we had we had a we had a band in
the oil yeah you know and so it was all
about the event it wasn't just about
putting a show together it was about
creating an event for the for the
audience and he was in hell because he
couldn't concentrate he needed he wanted
to go away and concentrate but there was
no quiet place